eigentlich ist das ende des universums
noch lange nicht absehbar als dehnt sich
immer weiter aus bisher war vermutet
worden dass es so langsam aber sicher
stirbt den sternen
geht der brennstoff auto und irgendwann
wird es so kalt dass ich natürlich jetzt
sagt aber ein forschungsteam der harvard
university ein anderes ende voraus ein
einziges instabiles higgs boson wird das
universum zerstören und diese zerstörung
könnte schon begonnen haben jetzt bei
pixum science fiction herzlich
willkommen tja das universum dehnt sich
immer weiter aus und was wir die
forschung wirklich verblüffend ist diese
ausdehnung wird immer schneller
vermutet wird als grund die dunkle
energie 13,8 milliarden jahre ist unser
universum alten bereits im 10 milliarden
jahren wird von der erde aus kaum noch
eine galaxie zu sehen sein
sie sind dann einfach zu weit weg schon
heute sterben sterne und es werden immer
mehr bis sie alle kleinen und noch
schwach schimmernde weiße zwerge oder
eben schwarze löcher sind es wird dunkel
so war bisher die vorstellung vom ende
des universums doch wahrscheinlich
passiert etwas anderes hat jetzt ein
forschungsteam der harvard university
herausgefunden das ergebnis ihrer studie
ein einziges instabiles higgs boson wird
zu einer riesigen kettenreaktion führen
die das gesamte universum zerstören wird
eine riesige explosion
das explosion ist das teilchen das allen
teilchen erst die masse verleiht also
ein ziemlich entscheidendes
elementarteilchen erst 2012 wurde es am
lhc dem large hadron collider dem
riesigen teilchenbeschleuniger in genf
gefunden das hat selbst eine ziemlich
große masse und zwar so groß wie zwei
eisenatome ihrer studie nach ändert ein
einziges explosionen in diesem prozess
seine masse und wird damit der
stabilisiert in der folge ergreift eine
riesige explosion das weltall und es
wird quasi in einem zweiten urknall
zerstört irgendwo in der gekrümmten raum
zeit um ein schwarzes loch kann dieser
prozess seinen anfang nehmen in diesen
extrem seltsamen regionen können
teilchen in ihrer interaktion auch sehr
extrem beeinflusst werden was die
veränderung der masse eines exposés zur
folge haben könnte und es könnte schon
begonnen haben nur sei das higgs boson
dann so weit entfernt
dass wir es nicht feststellen können
zitat es sieht aus als wenn wir genau an
der kante zwischen einem stabilen und
einem instabilen universum werden wir
sind eben an einen punkt an dem das
universum sehr lange existieren kann
aber irgendwann ein großer knall kommt
das sagte der physiker josef lüken von
fermi national accelerator labors der
sun er war dicht an der studie beteiligt
aber auch die forschungsgruppe gibt
entwarnung auch wenn das higgs boson
bereits instabil geworden sein könnte
rechnen sie mit dem daraus
resultierenden knall in einer wirklich
sehr sehr weit entfernten zeit wenn das
universum bereits unendlich viel länger
schon kalt und tod ist in achtung 10
hoch 139 jahren dafür gibt es ein wort
das im 10
presse wie gehen die lionen eine zahl
mit 139 0
eine milliarde hatten 99 es ist also
unvorstellbar lange noch hin und sie
haben auch ein mindestalter des
universums berechnend 10 hoch 58 jahre
das sind leichter auszusprechen zehn
milliarden auch das ist unvorstellbar
lange in die zukunft wenn ihr bis dahin
hierbei klicks um nichts verpassen wollt
dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei
whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor
allen anderen
vom neuesten video garantiert und zu
beginn dieses beitritts zur whatsapp
community habe ich noch ein kleines
geschenk für euch einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das
aber mit der blogger vergessen und hier
geht es weiter dafür auch draufklicken
gab es keinen urknall ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran